it's been over a year since apple
launched max safe and for those that use
it it has been a true game changer not
only for the perfect alignment while
charging but various accessories that
make life easier and today we are
covering 10 new killer magsafe
accessories both on a budget and higher
end as well let's start out with this
gooseneck holder that costs just 17
bucks by the way all 10 of these will be
linked down in the video description
below and this allows you to easily
mount your phone for a variety of uses
at the perfect angle and height at the
bottom we have an adjustable clamp so
you can mount it to your desk headboard
or anywhere really it then has a
flexible gooseneck that allows you to
have the perfect angle for your phone
for taking videos and photos face timing
or anything else i was worried that the
adjustable bar would be too weak but it
is actually crazy strong so it has no
issues holding up even an iphone 13 pro
max with a large case amazon shows it
being mounted to a headboard so you can
watch videos without having to hold your
phone or recording overhead shots for
social media or really anything else
that you want you can even use it to
hold up your phone to use the flashlight
feature if you are working on something
and you need both hands personally i'm
going to use it for taking group photos
instead of having to get out a tripod
with a phone holder and it is very
portable because you can actually just
flex this bar and it gets nice and
compact if you want to throw it in a bag
or somewhere else so for 17 bucks you
can't really lose out by having this in
your mac safe arsenal now we have
covered many wallets but this one is by
far the most secure one out there the
sinji moru m band is made in korea and
they quote that its magnet strength is
more than double compared to apple's
magnet and we believe them with that its
anti-twist magnet at the bottom is also
super strong and if that is somehow not
enough for you they include a band that
locks into a case and ties your wallet
to your phone which you can then
disconnect by unscrewing so you will be
guaranteed to never lose this wallet
personally i don't think that you need
it but it is a nice little extra for
those that worry about that now that's
not the only feature it also has a
built-in flap that you don't have to use
but you can if you want your cards to be
sealed in without any risk of those
falling out and on top of that there's
an adjustable rubber strap at the back
that can be used to give you a better
grip for your phone like one of the ring
things that people use with them and it
can also double as a little stand if
you're going to be watching videos on
your phone it can prop it up the
materials also feel premium and costing
less than half of what apple's while it
costs while being more secure this thing
is a no-brainer and we finally have
something that is ultra safe for those
of you guys that worry about losing the
wallet or your cards now if that's too
extreme for you they also make this
wallet which is way more minimalistic
but still high quality with strong
magnets and its standout feature is that
they use neoprene to hold your cards so
if you avoided max safe wallets because
they only had two or three card
capacities you can stuff five or more
into this one the material can stretch
to hold a lot of cards but don't worry
about them slipping out because the back
side is a really nice rubbery plastic
that grips your cards really well now
the magnets aren't as strong as the m
band but they are still stronger than
apples while being nice and slim and
costing only 15 to 18 bucks depending on
the color that you choose i'm glad that
we finally have some great unique and
secure wallets on the market now
compared to the cheap knockoffs that we
tested just about a year ago speaking of
knockoffs this one is really cool and
for a great price
this mac safe duo ripoff is just hitting
the market but instead of supporting two
devices it actually supports three now i
have been using this other duo copy for
a while now when traveling and it has
done a good job but just like apple's
expensive version it can't charge my
airpods on it while charging my phone
and my watch but this one actually gives
you
two cheap charging pads one on each side
of the watch so you can charge your air
pods your phone and the apple watch or
say two different smartphones as well
when it first launched people complained
about being flaky so they now include a
power adapter with it in the box that
can handle three devices unlike apple
where you have to buy that on your own
and it is only 38
the quality of this one is way better
than my previous one with rubber that
feels much like apple's versions and the
magnets are stronger as well when you
fold it it magnetizes together to itself
so it's very compact it's nice for
throwing in your bag taking with you and
even if you want to just use it as home
as an alternative to something else it's
really hard to beat at this price now of
course it won't give you full 15 watt
maxi charging speeds but it tops out at
the standard 7.5 watt g charging but
apple's duo also won't give you that
speed and that one also slows down more
if you're charging your watch at the
same time now if you want to step it up
a notch and you want something that will
not only give you the fastest charging
for your iphone but also your apple
watch as well this is belkin's new boost
up charge pro it's an upgrade to their
older three-in-one stand where your
phone and watch floats but in a slim
minimalistic package that can be easily
taken with you on the go you get the
benefit of knowing it is high quality
it's gonna last a long time and it's the
only other brand that apple actually
allows to use the full magsafe fast
charging and it's only one of three
chargers that can fast charge the series
seven and future apple watches so you're
gonna know that you're future-proof my
next recommendation is also from belkin
and it is their updated magnetic car
vent mount the first version was
released at the same time as iphone 12s
but had a really large footprint and a
few limitations this new one is very
similar and it has some unique features
but in a smaller and slimmer package
that it's also lighter the magnets are
strong and the magnetic plate swivels so
you can easily change from portrait to
landscape orientation without having to
remove it now there isn't any wireless
charging built in but instead it secures
a lightning cable at the back the
benefit of that is that you get faster
and more efficient charging compared to
wireless and with most cars you need
that connection for apple carplay my
next find is this thin aluminum magsafe
mount it can be used for many things and
is designed to swivel so you can hide it
behind flat objects at only 16 bucks it
has strong 3m mounting tape and it's
advertised to attach to your laptop and
magnetically hold your iphone next to
your screen of course we can use it for
way more than that like for example if
you drive a newer car with a tablet like
floating display you get to attach it to
that and then use other navigation apps
which is how i'm going to be using it or
anywhere else that is flat now for those
of you who have older cars or trucks or
if you have a weird dash that doesn't
have a flat area for mounting or if you
just don't want to use a vent mount or
you can't anchor has this crazy arm
thing that will fix your problem it is
crazy adjustable since the bar can be
lowered and raised and then it locks in
as well as the magnetic attachment plate
with its ball head so you can get the
perfect angle and position exactly where
you want your phone to be it does charge
your phone and it comes with everything
you need in the box like a cigarette
adapter in case you don't have a usb
port or one that is powerful enough so
now you guys do not have any excuses for
not having a capable magsafe solution
for your vehicle but what about
on-the-go charging well anker has
another solution for that as well and no
this video is not sponsored by anker or
any other company we bought all of these
ourselves
this is anker's new wireless charging
pack that comes in at just 60 bucks and
it destroys apple's solution it has the
same 5 000 milliamp hour battery
capacity that their previous one had
which we put head to head against apples
and it beat it in most ways but it is
now slimmer which they show off in their
own images it now comes with the two
year warranty and instead of having that
slippery plastic shell that i complained
about it has a nice rubbery finish with
good grip now it is not as fast charging
as apples but it also won't stop
charging if you're playing a game or
doing any kind of medium intensive test
and it can actually charge your phone
about 30 percent more than apple's
solution and along with that you can use
the usb type-c port to use as a wire
charging bank just like the other ones
which it's more efficient and more
flexible whereas this one you cannot use
that the other added bonus is the
built-in flush stand that folds out by
using a little tab that is kind of
hidden there and it allows you to prop
up your phone and portrait or using it
in landscape now overall this thing is
almost half the price of apples and it
is better in most ways while feeling
even higher quality so if you need a
wireless charging bank this is the one
to go for i have two more items to talk
about and both of them are charging
stands for your desk or your nightstand
but they are really different the
chiotek is a two in one where your phone
floats in the air and you can charge
airpods down below and for the money it
does a great job but of course you won't
get the fastest charging speeds from it
which is where the caseology one comes
in it uses a unique two piece design
that can be tilted from almost straight
up to a flat design which is helpful to
charge devices that don't have magnets
in them the base is lightweight but it
does have a sticky to hold it in place
and the quality is nice and it
definitely looks different compared to
almost every other stand out there which
is a bonus now you do have to buy a mac
safe puck to put into it but that is
also what gets you the fastest charging
speeds possible so i'm going to be
switching to this thing for my desk so
there you guys have it 10 brand new mac
safe accessories for 2022
some of them are new and some are great
updates to previous versions all of them
are linked down below in the video
description so go ahead and check those
out and if you want we have two other
great videos on magsafe accessories
right over there click go ahead and
click above to subscribe if you guys
want to help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers we would definitely
appreciate it listen max and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]